votre rendez-vous avec l'actualité
africaine sur France 24 c'est maintenant
très heureux de vous retrouver à la une
ce soir ce couvre-feu décrété au Tchad
après des affrontements meurtriers au
moins 50 morts et 300 blessés lors de
rassemblement contre débit un président
de transition qui s'accroche au pouvoir
selon ses opposants nous ferons le point
avec Mamadou jimbaby la transition
s'éternise également en Guinée et
cristallise les tensions les opposants
du fndc appelaient à la mobilisation ce
jeudi à Conakry des heures ont éclaté
cinq personnes auraient été blessées par
balle Malik Diakité et sur place
gaz lacrymogène et canon à eau à l’égoce
commémoration dans la violence de la
tuerie de l'équipe il y a deux ans des
manifestations contre les brutalités
policières c'était terminé par des coups
de feu et des morts
le Tchad compte ses morts le bilan des
manifestations qui ont secoué le pays
notamment
de la journée 50 tués et 300 blessés au
moins annoncé en soirée le Premier
ministre bien rassemblements étaient
organisé par l'opposition elle veut une
accélération de la transition les
élections ont été repoussées à 2024
Antoine Mariotti
mettre un terme à un pouvoir dynastique
c'est avec ces mots qu'une partie de
l'opposition tchadienne justifie sa
mobilisation elle avait lancé mercredi
un appel à manifester pacifiquement pour
demander aux militaires de retourner
dans leur caserne comme il s'était
engagé il y a tout juste 18 mois les
morts se comptent désormais par dizaines
l'opposant succès massera du parti les
transformateurs assurent que l'armée
fait feu même sur les ambulances dans la
cour des hôpitaux il nous tire dessus il
tue notre peuple les soldats du sol
général qui a refusé d'honorer sa parole
et aujourd'hui c'est la fin des 18 mois
voilà comment il entend installer la
dynastie en tuant le peuple toujours sur
Twitter le président de l'Union
africaine condamne fermement la
répression des manifestations le
gouvernement rejette lui la faute sur
les tchadiens qui sont descendus dans la
rue des insurgés selon lui qui ont tenté
un coup d'état très tôt la nuit dernière
ils se sont répartis en petits groupes
armés de gourdin
je m'achète deux flèches et de
lance-pierre
leur technique éprouvée acquises par
plus de 1500 jeunes lors d'une récente
formation à la guérilla urbaine était
une mobilité constante et rapide après
chaque coup perpétrée les autorités sur
que les manifestants attaqué notamment
le gouverneur à le siège du parti du
Premier ministre et celui du président
de l'Assemblée nationale un couvre-feu
est imposé de 18h à 6h du matin jusqu'au
retour au calme dans la capitale et les
principales villes touchées par ces
violences quant aux partis politiques
impliquées leur activité publique ont
été suspendues par le gouvernement
et des violences que condamne la France
Paris qui a d'ailleurs démenti les
rumeurs quant à son application
éventuelle dans ces événements
condamnation aussi des États-Unis et qui
appellent à la désescalade et l'ONU
enfin à elle de son côté réclamé une
enquête on retrouve tout de suite notre
correspondant à jamena Mamadou bonjour
vous vous êtes donc notre correspondant
le Premier ministre on l'a on l'a vu
tchadir a pris la parole il a actualisé
le bilan mais il a surtout envoyé un
message clair à l'opposition et à toute
forme de contestation d'ailleurs
tout à fait il a envoyé un message de
fermeté et il a appelé que l'État ne se
laissera pas faire et il a qualifié ces
marches d'insurrection et il a une
excellente que elle est manifestants
étaient pour la plupart armée d'armes à
feu d'arts blanches et bien d'autres
outils qui pouvaient faire mal et en
donnant le bilan il a rappelé aussi que
dans ces 50 morts on relève 15 morts du
côté des forces de l'ordre donc il a il
s'est voulu vraiment très très ferme
bien que lui-même soit issu l'opposition
et il était ancien membre du mouvement
citoyen qui est à l'appel de cette
marche monotorisée il a rappelé que
lorsqu'il était dans ce mouvement il a
toujours prôné la voix de l'aspect et
d'une marche pacifique c'est une
illustration finalement des soubresauts
de la vie politique tchadienne ces
derniers mois depuis que Mama débit a
appris le pouvoir à lors de son père
aucune élection n'a été organisée malgré
les promesses la période de transition
qui se finissait ce jeudi a même été
prolongée deux ans en début du mois
oui alors sachez que lorsque le
président actuel de la
transitions il a été mis en place un
comité unitaire de transition ce comité
c'est engagé à respecter certains
préalables et il s'est pitié les
objectifs à attendre dans les 18 mois
notamment les élections à la fin de
cette 18 mois ce qui n'a pas été
possible parce que de la vie de
plusieurs experts et analyse était
quasiment impossible de tenir des
élections dans les délais de 18 mois
compte tenu de plusieurs obstacles et
autres donc sur la feuille de route qui
se sont fixées il manque la case
élection mais ils ont reçu à organiser
le dialogue national dialogue qui a été
testé par une partie de l'opposition
notamment tous les mouvements qui ont
appelé pour la marche de ce de ces merci
beaucoup madame pour toutes ces
précisions depuis chamena la capitale
tchadienne les manifestations ont été
généré aussi en Guinée cinq personnes
auraient été blessées par balle selon le
fndc le parti d'opposition dissout par
la jante avait appelé à se mobiliser il
réclame un retour du pouvoir au civils
au plus vite c'est le souhait aussi de
la CEDEAO présente cette semaine dans le
pays elle a donné aux autorités de
transition jusqu'à samedi pour mettre
sur pied un nouveau calendrier sur place
malgré l'interdiction de toute
manifestation dans le pays par les
militaires cette journée a été très
tendue dont les quartiers damdala
bambetta dans la banlieue de Conakry des
affrontements ont éclaté entre des
jeunes manifestants et les forces de
l'ordre avec le gel de pierre d'un côté
et tire de gaz lacrymogène de l'autre
toujours sur l'axe les manifestants ont
barricadé les routes brûler les pneus
empêchant toutes sortes les commerces
station de service sont restés fermés
une forte mobilisation des forces de
l'ordre l'Autrement armé était visible
sur le terrain à leur tête le chef de la
gendarmerie guinéenne moi je suis juste
de passage pour voir un peu le bon
fonctionnement du dispositif de
prévention qui a été lancé depuis hier
soir
si le dispositif il fonctionne
effectivement en fonction des consignes
l'autre constat est que la population
sur l'axe est fortement intimidé à
travers les propagandes sur les médias
fortement terrorisé donc nous on est
obligé de prendre nos responsabilités
les rassurer le Front national pour la
défense de la Constitution une coalition
dissaute par les autorités guinéennes
dedans sont depuis quelques mois la
gestion de la transition par les
militaires le mouvement était déjà à
l'initiative des manifestations du 28 et
22 juillet dernier interdite par les
militaires au pouvoir celle-ci avait
dégénéré et 5 personnes avaient été tué
nous sommes le 20 octobre une date
indélébile dans l'esprit de nombreux
nigérian il y a deux ans un mouvement
contre la répression policière avait été
réprimé dans le sang au péage de
l'équipe ensaals c'est son nom a été
commémoré ce jeudi dans la violence et
avec un besoin de justice Laurent
Berchet
de retour sur les lieux du drame deux
ans après la tuerie du péage de l'équipe
des centaines de manifestants se sont
rassemblés pour rendre hommage aux
victimes et demander des comptes au
gouvernement
tout le monde sait ce qui s'est passé
ici le 20 octobre 2020 le gouvernement
massacré ses propres citoyens et pas
seulement à l'équipe mais un peu partout
à l'ego c'est au Nigeria deux ans plus
tard nous n'avons toujours pas obtenu
justice
en 2020 le Nigéria est secoué par une
série de manifestations contre les
violences policières mais le mouvement
ensa connaît une fin tragique le 20
octobre lorsqu’une dizaine de personnes
sont tuées au péage de l'équipe de
nombreux témoins accusent les forces de
sécurité d'avoir ouvert le feu sur un
rassemblement pacifique une version des
faits soutenu par Amnesty internationale
et corroborée par une commission
d'enquête indépendante l'année dernière
mais le gouvernement et l'armée continue
de nier ses accusations et affirme avoir
tiré des balles à blanc deux ans plus
tard aucune responsabilité n'a été
établie tandis que plus de 40 personnes
arrêtées pendant les manifestations sont
encore derrière les barreaux
des citoyens ont été arrêtés pendant le
mouvement Ansars ils sont toujours en
prison le gouvernement doit prendre ses
responsabilités nous ne les laisserons
pas oublier cette affaire
ces nouvelles manifestations ont lieu
alors colonie géria doit se rendre aux
urnes en février prochain pour élire un
successeur au président muhamadou Buhari
une simulation d'assaut au djihadistes
grandeur nature au Togo où elle a eu
lieu au centre d'entraînement aux
opérations de maintien de la paix de
Lomé la capitale de faux terroristes de
faux otages de faux blessés mais de
vraiment membres des forces de l'ordre
au total une quarantaine de gendarmes et
de policiers ont été mobilisés pour
l'exercice le but paré à la menace qui
pèse sur le pays notamment depuis près
d'un an au moins 5 attaques ont été
menées depuis novembre 2021
essentiellement à la frontière dans le
Nord donc avec le Burkina Faso
de jeunes étudiants maliens ont décidé
de jouer kart sur table leur projet vise
à répertorier les rues les égouts les
zones de dépose des déchets de Bamako le
but une cartographie digitale pour mieux
se déplacer se repérer et faire de la
capitale malienne une ville intelligente
Laurent
à la main Amadou Menta et son équipe
Sion Méru du quartier Daoudabougou à
Bamako chaque caniveau et bouche des
goûts sont soigneusement répertoriées
dans une base de données afin de créer
une carte digitale du système de
drainage dans ce quartier de la capitale
la cartographie
ces jeunes Maliens contribuent au projet
collaboratif open StreetMap lancée en
2004 les données collectées sont
stockées et mises à disposition du
public afin d'aider au développement de
la ville dans le quartier de Daouda
bouguou régulièrement touché par les
inondations cette initiative pourrait
aider les autorités à cibler les
problèmes plus rapidement le maire n'est
pas de son bureau n'avait aucune
information sur ce qui se passe
réellement aujourd'hui à travers un clic
il peut accéder à ces informations et
même être en contact avec les
responsables pour pouvoir avoir des
informations à chaud que nous n'avons
pas beaucoup de ressources et nous
comprenons qu'avec eux il y a la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir un
accompagnement sans dépenser beaucoup
d'argent
égout est canalisation mais aussi
collecte des déchets ou transports
publics autant de secteurs auxquels le
Data mapping pourrait contribuer à
Bamako mais aussi dans d'autres
mégalopoles africaines
c'est la fin de votre journal de
l'Afrique le reste de l'actualité
internationale c'est dans quelques
minutes avec Céline Bay moi je vous
retrouve à 22h40 à tout à l'heure
[Musique]